T
GREATNESS.
HERE NOW TO RESPOND IS A LOT TO
DEAL WITH HERE FORMER ACTING
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE RIC GRENELL, RICK,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE WITH ME.
I DO APPRECIATE IT.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE HERE AS WE
HAVE LEARNED MORE ABOUT THE
GHANI CONVERSATION, LEGACY MEDIA
HAS KIND OF IGNORED WHAT GHANI
TOLD THE PRESIDENT, WHAT'S YOUR
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT ALL THIS IS
LEADING UP TO HERE?
>> ARE I AM NOT SURPRISED THAT
WASHINGTON, D.C. IS LYING TO US
AGAIN.
UNFORTUNATELY, TAMMY, WE HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE WASHINGTON,
D.C.'S POLITICS HAS LITERALLY
KILLED AMERICANS.
AND WHILE THIS CAN GO ON IN
WASHINGTON AND THOSE IN
WASHINGTON CAN PAPER IT OVER AND
TRY TO SPIN THAT THEY GOT 90% OF
AMERICANS OUT OF AFGHANISTAN,
THE REST OF US OUTSIDE OF
WASHINGTON ARE SAYING WE HAVE
NEVER SEEN A SITUATION WHERE
WASHINGTON, D.C. POLITICIANS ARE
PROUD OF 90%.
WHAT WE HEAR, WHAT THE REST OF
US HERE IS THAT YOU LEFT 10% OF
THE PEOPLE IN AFGHANISTAN AND
YOU'RE TRYING TO SPIN THIS.
I REALLY NEVER THOUGHT THAT I
WOULD SEE THIS MOMENT COME.
NOW WE HAVE INTELLIGENCE
OFFICERS WHO ARE LEAKING AGAINST
DEMOCRATS IT'S SO BAD.
AND I DON'T LIKE THAT.
I DON'T LIKE WHEN INTELLIGENCE
OFFICERS DO BUT THEY DID IT
CONSTANTLY AGAINST PRESIDENT
TRUMP NOW THEY ARE DOING IT
AGAINST JOE BIDEN.
I THINK WHAT WE HAVE NOW, TAMMY,
IS IT'S LESS OF REPUBLICAN VS.
DEMOCRAT RIGHT NOW AS FIGHTING
AND IT'S WASHINGTON VS. THE REST
OF AMERICA.
YOU KNOW, EVERY GREAT SIZZLES
HAS LASTED ROUGHLY 250 YEARS.
WE ARE BUTTING UP AGAINST THAT.
I THINK IT'S SHAMEN US.
THIS HAS HAPPENED TO US SO MANY
TIMES, WE AMERICANS, WE HAVE GOT
STOP APOLOGIZING.
WE HAVE GOT TO STOP PRETENDING
LIKE WASHINGTON, D.C. IS EVER
GOING TO CHANGE ITSELF.
IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT CHANGING ITSELF.
WE HAVE TO GET INVOLVED.
RONALD REAGAN TOLD EVERY
GENERATION YOU HAVE GOT TO FIGHT
FOR YOUR FREEDOM.
AND I THINK EVERYBODY LISTENING
TO US TONIGHT HAS GOT TO RISE
UP.
THEY HAVE GOT TO REALIZE
WASHINGTON ISN'T CHANGING.
YOU HAVE GOT CHANGE WASHINGTON.
YOU HAVE GOT TO DIG A TRENCH SO
THAT WE CAN GET FRESH WATER INTO
WASHINGTON.
I LOVE LISA McCLAIN BECAUSE
SHE IS A FRESHMAN CONGRESSWOMAN
FROM MICHIGAN.
SHE IS PERPLEXED THAT WASHINGTON
CAN LIKE THIS.
>> Tammy: YOU CAN TELL.
>> I LOVE THAT SHE WILL CONTINUE
TO FIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO GO TO
WASHINGTON AND LOOK AT THE PLACE
AND SAY WHAT?
>> Tammy: RICK, THAT'S WHAT WE
ALL HAVE TO DO.
THERE IS A TENDENCY HERE TO
RETREAT IN GENERAL.
THAT'S WHAT THE SWAMP WANTS.
THAT'S WHAT THIS MONSTER WANTS.
>> WE CAN'T.
>> Tammy: THEY WANT TO EXHAUST
US.
WE UNDERSTAND BEING IN THERE
ITSELF HAS GOT TO BE DIFFICULT.
BUT AS AMERICANS, WE HAVE GOT TO
CONTINUE TO BE HEARD.
WE HAVE GOT TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY KNOW WHAT WE FEEL.
WE HAVE GOT TO STAND IN FRONT OF
THIS AND JUST LIKE WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT 90% WERE SAVED.
IT SHOWS YOU THAT THE GOVERNMENT
CERTAINLY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION LOOKS AT HUMAN
BEINGS AS CASH TAGS ON A PIECE
OF PAPER.
AND.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD SEE
THIS DAY.
>> Tammy: 10%, FAT CONTENT.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> LOOK, I THINK THAT PEOPLE
HAVE GOT TO STOP WORRYING ABOUT
CANCEL CULTURE.
IT'S TIME THAT WE FIGHT BACK.
WHEN YOU HEAR SOMEBODY STAND UP,
STAND WITH THEM.
>> Tammy: GREAT POINT.
>> SUPPORT THEM.
THEY CAN'T CANCEL ALL OF US.
THE REALITY IS WE ARE HALF THE
ECONOMY.
WE ARE HALF THE POPULATION
PROBABLY A LITTLE BIT MORE.
GET ACTIVE.
SPEAK UP.
DON'T BE ALONE.
>> Tammy: THANK YOU, SIR.
GREAT POINT BECAUSE FRANKLY IT'S
MORE THAN 80% OF US ARE OUTRAGED
ABOUT THIS.